and what is it like to be targeted by
the way for your political beliefs by a
fool the full force of the federal
government well we're gonna ask the man
just pardoned by President Trump
conservative filmmaker and author
danette de Souza de Souza thanks for
being with us tonight boy this pardon
has set off a firestorm of freak-outs
among people on the left and today we
had an especially big freakout from a
former Obama US Attorney Barbara McQuade
who was on MSNBC this morning let's
watch it concerns me that not only is he
violating the norms of not going through
that normal process but is he painting a
narrative that can be convenient for him
that sensitizes the public that the
government is sometimes and or maybe
even often very unfair to people which I
think has long-term damaging
consequences to the criminal justice
system the left has freaked out more
over my pardoned than maybe any other I
was watching something on CNN I think it
was earlier today or yesterday these
things become a blur and they were
saying how dangerous it is that I got
this pardon and and I was thinking about
that and it occurred to me that I think
I know what they're getting at it's it's
dangerous to them
it's dangerous to their ideology and
it's dangerous in a way that other
partners I mean think of the the Clinton
pardon of Mark rich you've got a guy
here who's an international arms trader
and possibly a tax fraud and involved in
all kinds of rackets but he's not
dangerous to the ideology at CNN in fact
he helps to support progressive causes
he gives money to the Clinton Foundation
I on the other hand I'm a non-white
immigrant I came to America with five
hundred dollars in my pocket and I've
been exposing the whole progressive
ideology so I'm dangerous in that way
they're right about that
John Avalon on CNN today was also I mean
again the media the the Democrats the
never Trump errs they're all questioning
why this occurred and let's watch what
are you supposed to think about this I
think you see this as a proud of the
power of the presidency means a get out
of jail free card but this is also
someone who's been a self-styled
conservative
electro who's really just been a Twitter
troll for a long period of time right
now appealing to all the worst instincts
and conspiracy theories well I've never
alleged any conspiracy by anyone what I
have done is exposed the sordid racist
history of the Democratic Party a
history that actually continues to the
present
I've also exposed a lot about Obama look
Obama would not have indicted me if I
didn't make a film that deeply upset him
I didn't just go against his ideology I
kind of got into his head
and sometimes when I speak on campus
people go well gee Dinesh what makes you
think that Obama even saw your dumb
movie or even cares about anything you
have to say well the reason I think that
is because he was attacking me on his
personal website barackobama.com so
there you go this is a narcissistic
president who who believed in the
vendetta and recruited goons like Eric
Holder and freed Pereira to then carry
his water form to go after me and every
little CNO the indication of my case
shows that that subscribe to their
liberal ideology Dinesh their point is
that people like you and and people like
me we're just we're all too right do you
notice how that's changed now you're not
a conservative and you're not winning in
the arena of ideas you're all right or
your xenophobic or I love it when they
call you racist that's always fun and so
it's it's a way to avoid an argument a
debate we saw this going back to college
Dinesh and I went to college together at
Dartmouth College way back before they
called it political correctness they
were trying to avoid the fundamental
debate about the the greatness of
Western civilization how off track they
have been on so many issues the decline
of a true intellectual thought and
diversity of thought they didn't want
that debate they wanted to shut down
debate which is in line with wanting to
shut frankly you down or even this show
I mean here's a tiny detail about my
case that's so revealing this Clinton
appointed judge who adjudicated my case
the same guy who said oh no there's no
political targeting here
as part of my sentence he sentences me
to mandatory Saiki
Adric counseling now let's think about
this for a minute what about my case
here I've given too much money or my own
money to a candidate a college friend of
mine running for office
I'm not Jeffrey Dahmer I didn't put
bodies in the refrigerator why do I need
psychiatric counseling if not that it's
the progressive view that I'm not just
wrong but I'm somehow crazy that people
who disagree with them require not
persuasion but therapy and so this is a
kind of reeducation project that was
attempted on me and finally the judge
just became super frustrated and he
threw up his hands and basically said
the reeducation has failed this this man
cannot be psychologically rehabilitated
which I took as a great compliment they
tried she should have put you up on the
rack maybe they should have waterboarded
you that that would actually been an
enhanced interrogation that they would
have supported on the Left Dinesh I
always want to get I also want to get
your thoughts on some comments made
tonight by Steve ban and featured
tonight on CNN he seems to be
re-entering the public arena he's been
over there in Italy maybe working on
that populist movement over there but he
said this regarding the Muller
investigation I've been a big proponent
of more I was the guy that said don't
fire Comey this thing's Peter now I've
always said you know he's a combat
marine great individual that ought to
play out as it's going to play out in
fairness Laura I just don't know what to
make of it I mean I will say that
actually Muller was the head of the FBI
when my case for a surfaced and the
Congressional Oversight Committee has
been trying to had been trying for a
while to get my FBI file and couldn't
and then finally they got it redacted
but in it it it identifies me as a
prominent critic of Obama and I think
that's very interesting because why is
that in my file this was a case of Lady
Justice being blind they're merely
investigating a campaign violation why
highlight my politics I think it's
because the FBI the Muller FBI was
signaling to the Justice Department the
holder Justice Department here's a guy
who's one of your political enemies
here's a guy you may want to go after so
this is the stuff that the left is doing
behind closed doors this
what makes people like like me dangerous
to them this is why I'm not an ordinary
conservative but somebody who ultimately
they would like to see locked up
well they've they've seen and they've
tried to silence conservatives before
again going all the way back to college
campuses they shut down speakers you've
had problem on college campuses
obviously Ann Coulter we're going to
talk to her and in a short while she's
had problems even even being able to
speak physically being allowed to speak
and participate and now that's being in
the Obama era
dinesh that was actually used as a
tactic intimidation following a fox news
reporter sharyl Attkisson thinks her
computer was broken into I mean these
are intimidation tactics that go beyond
the this stuff that would normally think
of so they're worried about Russia but
they're adopting the tactics of the old
Soviet Union it's it's stunning that
there's there's a deep level of lying
and deception that goes on here you know
that both Obama and Hillary were
disciples of Saul Alinsky dinesh what do
you think in the end happens to this
Democrat Party as it as it's moving
farther and farther leftward to me the
the party is in in many respects rotten
to the core and what's really holding it
up is not the Democratic Party itself
but by its own weight it would collapse
but it's sustained by a kind of outside
alliance involving people in academia
the left in the media and the left and
the entertainment industry the left
controls these three megaphones of our
culture and they can put out a huge
amount of big lies and disinformation as
long as that continues so they're what's
holding up the Democratic Party right
now they're the cover-up artists for
this party
dinesh d'souza thanks so much for giving
us your first primetime interview after
the pardon from President Trump thanks
ash